يجب ان نتفق على اليه تسعير الغاز والقاده
الاوروبيون اعطى وزراء الطاقه مهمه واضحه
ومحدده
اخبار الجزيره مرحبا بكم وزراء الطاقه
الاوروبيون يناقشون مقترحا جديدا لتحديد
سقف اسعار الغاز مفوضه طاقه الاوروبيه
قالت ان الاتفاق اصبح قريبا ويتطلب
تنازلات من الجميع ورئاسه الاتحاد تقول
انه تم وضعه معايير امنه لوقف العمل
بالقرار في حال حدوث عزه في الامداد
روسيا تقولوا ان سياسه الولايات المتحده
في اوكرانيا تدفع البلدين الى حافه
الاصطدام المباشر وتاكد ان جميع الاسلحه
المرسله سيتم تعقبها وتدميرها من جديد
طلبه دول اوروبيه بانظمه دفاع جوي وصواريخ
ودبابات وقالت بريطانيا انه لا مفاوضات
بدون الانسحاب الروسي من اوكرانيا
من الامن الاردني واصابه اخرين خلال
مداهمه مشتبهم به في قتل نائب مدير امن
معان السلطات واعلنت مقتله والقبض على
تسعه اخرين وقالت انها لن تتهاون في انفاذ
القانون وفرض السياده على من يحاول
الاخلال
في ختان كاس العالم قطر 2022 امير دوله
قطر يقول ان بلاده اوففت بوعدها بتنظيم
بطوله استثنائيه من بلاد العرب في حين
تصدرت تهنئه قطر على تنظيم البطوله من
اقساط التواصل بالاضافه الى البشت بعد
البسه لمسه خلال التتويش
الى اللقاء